after seven deaths and hundreds of
injured demonstrators and security
forces one of ecuador's longest and most
conflictive strikes has ended
president guillen molasses tweeted we
have reached the supreme value that we
all aspire to peace in our country now
together we will work towards turning
this peace into progress well-being and
opportunities for all
18 days of nationwide roadblocks placed
by indigenous strikers and fierce
clashes between riot police and
demonstrators have cost ecuador an
estimated half a billion dollars
[Applause]
ecuador's powerful confederation of
indigenous nations which is made up
mainly of farming communities had
demanded sharp cuts in fuel prices food
and fertilizers
the president should not have waited for
people to die or be injured or lose
their eyes before listening to our
demands
president guillermo lasso a conservative
banker finally caved in to pressure to
reduce petrol and diesel but only by 15
cents a gallon far less than what the
strikers had originally demanded
[Music]
they were angry that their leaders had
accepted the deal
still the government did agree not to go
ahead with plans to expand oil and
mining in indigenous territories
as well as to improve education and
health services for people like mercedes
tamayo she says she can barely walk and
has been waiting for four months for a
doctor to see her because she can't
afford private health care
my father used to come here to fight for
land reform may he rest in peace this
president has never governed for the
poor just like his predecessor
in the end both sides had to make
concessions but as the strikers left the
capital to return to their communities
their leaders warned that it might only
be temporary they say that they've given
the government 90 days to prove that
they will follow through on their
commitments
lucian newman al jazeera quito ecuador